en B il y est
pas je pourrais savoir pourquoi tu
fouilles dans mes affaires je cherche le
mot épicurieux dans le dictionnaire et
je le trouve pas et pourtant je suis pas
fou il y a 16 millions d'abonnés qui le
connaissent tu le trouveras pas c'est un
mot que j'ai inventé au moment de la
création de la chaîne ah bon on peut
inventer des mots absolument et
d'ailleurs je suis sûr que tu utilises
aujourd'hui des mots qui n'existaient
pas il y a 10 ans
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à la
découverte de la vie secrète des mots à
la Cité internationale de la langue
française à villercotré dans l'INE et
vous allez voir que de leur naissance à
leur disparition la vie des mots est
pleine de rebondissement un véritable
romand d'aventure je vous raconte tout
cela de A à
[Musique]
Z le monument qui se trouve derrière moi
a marqué l'histoire de France en aût
1539 c'est dans ce château de Viller
côré que François 1er a signé
l'ordonnance qui porte le même nom à
partir de cette date tous les textes
officiel du royaume puis de la
République doivent être rédigés en
français toutes les décisions de justice
tous les textes de loi deviennent
compréhensible par un plus grand nombre
de personnes avant cette loi c'est latin
qui était roi les ancêtres de la plupart
des mots que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
sont arrivés dans les valises de Jules
César et de ses légionnaire au 1er
siècle avant Jésus-Christ au moment de
la conquête de la gaulle les Romains
parlent le latin une langue qui va
s'imposer sur l'ensemble du territoire
et aujourd'hui encore plus de 80 % de
notre vocabulaire en est issu au fil des
siècles les mots se sont métamorphosés
retracer leur transformation permet de
remonter aux origines de ces mots et de
mieux comprendre l'évolution de leur
signification cette discipline de fin
limier s'appelle
[Musique]
l'étymologie prenons l'adjectif curieux
dont je me suis servi pour créer le mot
épicurieux tout est partie du mot cura
qui en latin signifie le soin le souci
son dérivé l'adjectif
curiosus qualifiait à l'origine une
personne qui prenait soin des choses qui
s'en inquiétait et puis avec le temps ce
sens a glissé au 16e siècle un curieux
est une personne désireuse de savoir ou
de voir une personne qui s'inquiète
toujours mais qui s'inquiète de ce qui
se passe chez le voisin à l'époque c'est
plutôt mal vu il faut attendre le siècle
des Lumières qui célèbre l'appétit pour
la science et le savoir pour que la
curiosité ne soit plus vue comme un
vilain défaut enfin de fil en aiguille
de nombreux mots peuvent dériver d'une
même racine latine ainsi au fil du temps
cura a donné un curable cure curé mais
les mots peuvent parfois apparaître de
façon plus brutale un néologisme c'est
le terme savant pour désigner un mot
nouveau qui apparaît dans une langue et
comme pour beaucoup coup de concepts
scientifiques techniques ce mot
néologisme est né de la fusion de deux
mots grecs Néos qui signifie nouveau et
logos la parole avec les mots fusionnés
pas besoin de dictionnaire pour
comprendre leur sens il suffit de les
découper démonstration en
1792 un nouvel appareil voit le jour il
permet d'envoyer des message à distance
et sera donc naturellement baptisé
télloin graph message au 19e siècle il
est détrôné par le
téléphone pour se parler à distance et
tout récemment par le smartphone un
téléphone
[Musique]
intelligent avec cette technique on peut
créer des mots surmesure à chaque
découverte ou dès qu'il faut expliquer
un nouveau phénomène alors piocher dans
le vocabulaire grec ça fait très chic
mais ça marche aussi très bien avec mots
qui existent déjà en
[Musique]
français en amalgamant les verbes
divulguer et gâché pour former
divulgâcher nos cousins québécois ont
brillamment traduit le concept anglais
de spoiler vous savez cette fâcheuse
habitude qu' certain de révéler la fin
de l'histoire je déteste ça ce type de
néologisme qui repose sur la syllabe
commune de deux mots pour les fusionner
s'appelle un mot valise tenez pensez au
dernier courriel que vous avez rédigé en
frlais ah mais ça me rappelle un autre
mot
ép curieux parfaitement j'ai fusionné
les deux adjectifs
épicurien et curieux ok j'ai compris le
truc à mon
tour jouer avec les mots les remaniier
c'est le principal moteur de
l'enrichissement de notre vocabulaire
ces évolution passe souvent inaperçu car
beaucoup se font à la marge grâce à de
petits éléments qu'on ajoute en début ou
en fin de mots les fameux préfixes ou
suffix vous avez peut-être réservé un
covoiturage enfin de déconfinement pour
aller à la recyclerie la majorité des
nouveaux mots que nous utilisons vient
donc d'une évolution naturel du français
mais nous récupérons aussi des mots
ailleurs et attendez un peu avant de
crier à l'invasion de l'anglais pas la
peine d'aller si loin nous piochons
régulièrement dans le vocabulaire des
langues régionales le bastque le Breton
le catalan ou le provençal tenez si je
vous dis des Fada de jouer à la pétanque
sous un cannard pareil ce sont des
termes ocitant que nous connaissons tous
nous adoptons aussi des créations venues
d'autres pays francophones comme le mot
divulgaché dont on a déjà parlé tout à
l'heure mais bon pour tous les usages
liés aux nouvelles technologies on a
quand même tendance à Orter tel quel des
mots tout droit venus de Californie je
suis sûr que le streaming les podcasts
ou le scroll n'ont aucun secret pour
vous on ne peut pas empêcher les mots de
voyager après l'invasion des Francs le
latin que parl les Gaulois intègre des
bribes de langue germanique c'est
l'origine des verbes marcher danser
gagner au Moyen-Âge le vocabulaire
scientifique s'enrichit de termes arabes
on découvre l'alchimie l'algèbre les
élixirs les algorithmes puis à la
Renaissance les artistes se servent
allaigrement de mots venus d'Italie ils
peignent des aquarell compos des sonates
et des opéras avec la mondialisation les
nouveaux mots nous arrivent d'encore
plus loin peut-être avez-vous déjà lu un
manga en mangeant des sushis arrosé de
quelques gouttes de youzu
les mots en disent long sur l'histoire
des échanges entre les peuples ça y est
j'en tiens une gourmandise une
explication que l'on prend plaisir à
lire ou à entendre h pas sûr qu'il entre
de siôt dans le dictionnaire
celui-là et d'ailleurs savez-vous
comment un nouveau mot il fait son
entrée il y a plusieurs chemin parce
qu'il existe plusieurs dictionnaires le
premier auquel on pense c'est le
Dictionnaire de l'Académie française sa
première édition date de 1694 il
contenait à l'époque 18000 mots la 9e
édition devrait en compter entre 55 et
60000 il y a encore un peu de suspense
parce qu'elle est toujours en cours
d'élaboration ça fait plus de 50 ans que
les académiciens il travaillent et ils
n'en sont qu'à la lettre S S mais c'est
après le
G on n'est pas prêt de voir gourmudis
dans le Lico hein ils se réunissent tous
les jeudis matins et passent plus heures
à débattre de la définition de chaque
mot leurs travaux sont publiés au fur et
à mesure au Journal officiel alors c'est
vrai que les recommandations des
académiciens sont souvent relayées dans
la presse et très commandées mais elles
n'ont pas valeur de loi ouf je vais
pouvoir continuer à raconter n'importe
quoi ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'un mot n'a pas besoin d'être reconnu
par l'Académie française pour entrer
dans d'autres dictionnaires les deux
plus connus en France la rousse et le
Robert sont publiés par des maisons
d'édition privé qui sont totalement
libres et ne se privent pas d'intégrer
des mots rejetés par les immortels c'est
le surnom que l'on donne aux
académiciens qui gardent leur siège à
[Musique]
vie alors pourquoi certains mots entrent
dans le dictionnaire et d'autres pas
toute l'année les éditeurs du Larousse
et du Robert repèrent l'pparition de
nouveaux mots dans un article de journal
une chanson une publication scientifique
ou au détour d'une une banale
conversation dans le métro ils doivent
ensuite vérifier que l'usage de ce mot
est fréquent et répandu scruter ses
apparitions dans les médias la
littérature mais aussi de plus en plus
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un
indicateur précieux des logiciels
permettent d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de
recenser automatiquement la fréquence
d'emploi des mots deuxième critère
l'usage du nouveau mot doit durer dans
le temps et oui il faut éviter les
effets de mode du coup un néologisme
peut-être observé pendant plusieurs
années avant d'entrer dans le
dictionnaire si l'on examine quelques
néologismes admis ces dernières années
on remarque qu'ils ont un lien avec
l'actualité récente comme covid ou
vaccinodrome un lien avec les enjeux de
société comme mégabassine microplastique
écoanxiété ou grossophobie ou encore
avec les nouvelles technologies comme
métaver ou NFT chaque année ça fait donc
un paquet de nouvelles définitions à
ajouter pour que le dictionnaire reste
en phase avec son époque pour le
Larousse le quotat de nouveaux mots a
été fixé à 150 pour le Robert il n'y a
pas de quota mais ça tourne autour des
mêmes chiffres mais alors ils doivent
écrire de plus en plus petit pour tout
faire rentrer ils ont de puissant
logiciel de mise en page mais ça ne
suffit pas toujours chez la rousse les
mots les plus
poussiéreux sont poussés vers la sorti
10 % des termes que l'on trouvait dans
la première édition du Larousse de 1856
on par exemple é retiré on trouve au
cimetière des mots destitués des
adverbes tels que persévéramment
processionnellement des verbes comme
monseigneorisé ou magnétoscopé je l'ai
utilisé celui-ci ou encore des adjectifs
trop rarement employé comme zinzolin oh
dommage avec de Z il devait valoir des
points celui-ci au scrable je te rassure
il est encore dans l'édition en ligne et
puis j'ai un scoop à part pour les
puristes du
rien ne vous interdit d'utiliser des
mots qui ne figurent pas dans lesdic les
artistes ne s'en privent pas et les
journalistes non plus quand il parle par
exemple des trumpistes pour désigner les
partisans de l'ancien président
américain Donald Trump
[Musique]
entrer dans le dictionnaire ce n'est pas
la fin de l'aventure pour un mot notre
langue est vivante leur sens continue
d'évoluer au fil du temps on l'a bien vu
avec l'adjectif curieux et c'est vrai
pour beaucoup d'autres l'adjectif
formidable par exemple à l'origine était
synonyme de terrible redoutable
aujourd'hui on l'emploie dans le sens
merveilleux par ailleurs nous sommes 250
millions de francophones dans le monde à
parler français tous les jours de
conversation en conversation le sens des
mots continue de glisser et on arrive à
des sens parfois très différents en
fonction des pays ce qui peut engendrer
quelques malentendu au Québec par
exemple évitez de parler de vos gosses à
vos collègues le mot est employé dans la
belleprovince pour désigner les
testicules et ne vous offusquez pas si
un Suisse vous dit adieu quand vous le
rencontrez il vient simplement vous dire
bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour quant à moi je ne vous fais pas
encore mes adieux mais pour cette vidéo
voici venu le mot de la fin j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu et surtout si
vous aimez jouer avec les mots n'hésitez
pas à pousser la porte de la Cité
internationale de la langue française à
Viller côré c'est intriguant passionnant
étonnant je n'ai pas de mot voilà il est
maintenant l'heure de tourner la page je
vous souhaite une excellente semaine sur
les réseaux
[Applaudissements]
épicurieux